We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I'm not one of those people who romanticizes the edgier, grittier New York, but this park has been overrun with dogs and babies. And this is my friend Benjamin Walker reporting from New York City's Tomkin Square Park.
我们得到了UC Davis（加州大学戴维斯分校）的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。UC Davis的研究人员在加利福尼亚州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这全是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我不是那种会把更前卫、更残酷的纽约浪漫化的人，但这个公园已经被狗和婴儿占领了。这是我的朋友本杰明·沃克从纽约市汤普金广场公园发回的报道。
The first Tomkin Square riot took place in 1857. A bunch of unemployed immigrants tried to set the park on fire. And then in 1863, the parks saw more trouble when the ultra violent draft riots and gulfed the city. But it was the riot of 1874 that made Tomkin Square Park famous. Over 7,000 workers battled 1,600 police officers,
第一次汤普金广场暴动发生在1857年。一群失业的移民试图放火烧毁公园。然后在1863年，当极度暴力的征兵暴动席卷这座城市时，公园遇到了更多的麻烦。但正是1874年的暴动让汤普金广场公园闻名遐迩。超过7,000名工与1,600名警察展开了激战，
some on horseback swinging clubs. Early labor organizers, Samuel Gompers, described the riot as an orgy of brutality. In 1936, Robert Moses redesigned the park. He cut it into sections, and supposedly, he believed his design was riot proof. Well I guess what we know about that is it didn't work. Fish on Chakrabardi is a professor of architecture and design at Columbia University.
一些骑在马背上挥舞着警棍。早期的劳工组织者塞缪尔·冈珀斯将这场暴动描述为一场野蛮的狂欢。1936年，罗伯特·摩西重新规划了公园。他把它切成若干部分，并且据信，他认为他的设计是防暴的。嗯，我想我们对此的了解是它没有奏效。费山·查克拉巴蒂是哥伦比亚大学的建筑与设计教授。
In the late 80s he had a girlfriend who lived near Tomkin Square Park. So he experienced the riots of 1988 first hand. It was pretty extraordinary actually. You didn't wander wander around here too much at nighttime. Once again, activists battled it out with cops on horseback. But the difference with this riot is you can watch it on YouTube. It's all right, I'll get you down. I'll get you down.
在80年代末，他有一个住在汤普金广场公园附近的女朋友。所以他第一手经历了1988年的暴动。实际上相当非同寻常。夜里你可不会在这里闲逛太多次。又一次，积极分子与骑警展开了搏斗。但这场暴动与以往的不同之处在于你可以在YouTube上观看。没关系，我会把你弄下来的。我会把你弄下来的。
I'll get you down. In 1992, the park was redesigned again, and there hasn't been another riot. Yet, yet. There does seem to be a little bit of a deliberate intent to make it more of a place of circulation versus a place of repose. You know, one can imagine crowd control happening in a different way, now that there's
我会把你弄下来的。1992年，公园再次被重新规划，并且没有发生过另一场暴动。目前还没有。确实似乎有一种刻意为之的意图，使其更多地成为一个流通的场所，而不是一个休憩的场所。你知道的，人们可以想象人群控制会以不同的方式进行，既然现在有了
all these circulation pathways out, but no big belongs in which people can congregate. The height of the fence seems to keep growing. Chakrabardi recently wrote an essay on the architecture of public protest for the website Urban Omnibus. He examined some of the protests unfolding in the Middle East, but he's interested in the physical sites where thousands and thousands of people are coming together. The traffic circles of Bahrain and the large and open space that is Cairo, Takarir Square.
所有这些向外的流线通道，但没有人们可以聚集的大块区域。栅栏的高度似乎在不断增长。查克拉巴蒂最近为“城市全景”网站写了一篇关于公众抗议建筑学的文章。他审视了中东正在发生的一些抗议活动，但他对成千上万的人聚集在一起的实体场所很感兴趣。巴林的交通环岛以及开罗那片开阔的广场——塔哈里尔广场。
I think one of the most extraordinary sites when we looked at the protests from Terrier Square were that it was young and old, that there were children, and there were people who were clearly better off and clearly worse off. And I don't think that actions like that are possible in cities without broad swaths of public space. Chakrabadi recently toured the Middle East, and he learned that some authoritarian regimes are still keeping the Robert Moses Tomkin Square dream alive, designing for control. If you go to Riyadh, the capital of Saudi Arabia, here is the city of 4 million people, it's growing, and yet there are virtually no public spaces other than shopping malls. Actually, that's not exactly true.
我认为当我们审视来自塔里尔广场的抗议活动时，最非同寻常的场面之一就是里面有老有少，有儿童，有明显生活条件较好的人，也有明显生活条件较差的人。我不认为如果没有大片公共空间，城市里就会发生这样的行动。查克拉巴蒂最近游历了中东，他了解到一些威权政权仍在让罗伯特·摩西对汤普金广场的梦想延续下去，为控制而进行设计。如果你去沙特阿拉伯的首都利雅得，这是一个拥有400万人口的城市，它在不断增长，然而除了购物中心之外，几乎没有公共空间。其实，这并非完全准确。
There is a giant public square in Riyadh, Dira Square, but the only time the public is really allowed to congregate is when there are beheadings. That's why the expats call it Chop Chop Square. There's a sword drain, the diameter of a pizza in order to evacuate the blood. Chakrabardi says the Saudi royalty doesn't need to build fences at chop chop square or at the shopping malls because fear works just as well. The control doesn't need that much physical intervention to be understood by the populace. There's a clear understanding that if you break the
利雅得有一个巨大的公共广场——代拉广场，但公众真正被允许聚集的唯一时间是执行斩首的时候。这就是为什么外派人员称它为“砍头广场”。那里有一个披萨饼大小的排水沟，以便排干血液。查克拉巴蒂说，沙特王室不需要在砍头广场或购物中心建造栅栏，因为恐惧同样有效。这种控制不需要那么多的身体干预就能被民众理解。人们有一种清晰的理解，那就是如果你打破了
rules there are dire consequences. Now here in New York City's Tomkin Square to be understood by the populace. There is a clear understanding that if you break the rules, there are dire consequences. Now here in New York City's Tomkin Square Park, there is no pizza-sized blood drain, but there are fences that keep people from coming together, the way they did in 1988. And, you know, look, it was a very tense time in New York's urban history,
规则，就会产生可怕的后果。现在在纽约市的汤普金广场，被民众所理解。有一种清晰的理解，那就是如果你打破了规则，就会产生可怕的后果。现在在纽约市的汤普金广场公园，没有披萨大小的血槽，但有栅栏阻止人们像1988年那样聚集在一起。而且，你知道，听着，那是纽约城市历史上一个非常紧张的时期，
and a lot of the more peaceful protesters were protesting about affordable housing. And I think that was a very legitimate concern. And actually, I think it's really impacted policy. You know, today, the city of New York builds more affordable housing a year than the entire state of California. Vishan Chakra Party is not saying
许多比较温和的抗议者都在抗议可负担住房。我认为这是一个非常合理的关切。实际上，我认为它确实对政策产生了影响。你知道，如今，纽约市每年建造的可负担住房比整个加利福尼亚州还要多。维尚·查克拉巴蒂并不是在说
that open space necessarily leads to social change. But what he wants us to see when we watch those giant crowds in the Middle East The shocker party is not saying that open space necessarily leads to social change. But what he wants us to see when we watch those giant crowds in the Middle East on TV is this. One could argue that nations actually may not be able to change without the kind of activities that happen in the public spaces of cities. 99% invisible was produced this week by Benjamin Walker and me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity.
开放空间必然会导致社会变革。但他希望我们在电视上看到中东那些巨大的人群时看到的是这一点。人们可能会认为，如果没有城市公共空间中发生的这种活动，国家实际上可能无法改变。《99%隐形》本周由本杰明·沃克和制作人罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了用创意创造差异的 Lunar 的支持。
It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects San Francisco and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, go to 99%In me Roman Mars and I have a little bonus for the podcasters and website streamers. This week's story is from my friend Benjamin Walker and he has his own program on WFM you call too much information. And if you do not listen to too much information you have basically resigned yourself to have one hour of your week suck when it could actually be awesome.
这是KALW（美国旧金山建筑师学会）和建筑与设计中心的的一个项目。要了解更多信息，请访问 99%In 我是罗曼·马尔斯，我为播客和网站流媒体准备了一点小福利。本周的故事来自我的朋友本杰明·沃克，他在WFM上拥有自己的节目，叫做《太多信息》。如果你不听《太多信息》，你基本上就是让自己本来可以很棒的一周变得有一个小时糟糕透顶。
When I asked him to do a story for 99% invisible, I told him to highlight something that was kind of hidden, that has some greater thought and design put into it. I said, do a story like that penis graffiti story you did for TMI, but I can't use that one because I can't talk about genitalia for four minutes during morning edition. It's actually a really nice story about funny meaning when it's seemingly the most crude of artistic displays, but still too many penises for 730 in the morning. But alas, it's perfect for the podcast. So young master Gilbert, please check with your dad if it's okay, but for the rest of you,
当我请他为《99%隐形》做一个故事时，我告诉他要突出一些隐藏的、投入了更多思考和设计的东西。我说，做一个像你为TMI做的那个阴茎涂鸦的故事，但我不能用那个，因为我在早间版节目中不能连续四分钟谈论生殖器。这其实是一个非常好的故事，讲的是看似最粗俗的艺术展示背后蕴含的滑稽意义，但对于早上七点半来说，阴茎还是太多了。不过话又说回来，它非常适合做播客。所以，年轻的吉尔伯特大师，请向你爸爸确认一下这是否可以，但对于你们其他人来说，
this is Benjamin Walker, again, from his program, too much information. Gail and Smith lives in Brooklyn and works in Manhattan. And so he spends a lot of his time writing the subway and waiting for the subway. Living in New York, you know, you see a lot of graffiti and in the time period in which I've lived here, which is from like the 90s till now, it hasn't been real big classic 70s and 80s train murals. And it hasn't really been that famous New York style that really, you know, got the ball rolling all around the world.
这是本杰明·沃克，再次从他的节目《太多信息》中为您带来。盖林·史密斯住在布鲁克林，在曼哈顿工作。因此，他把大量时间花在坐地铁和等地铁上。住在纽约，你知道的，你会看到很多涂鸦，在我住在这里的这段时间里，也就是从90年代到现在，并没有真正出现那种大型经典的70和80年代的列车壁画。也没有真正出现那种真正让全世界都流行起来的著名纽约风格。
It's quick tags and quick throw ups, not so much big pieces. The majority of these quick tags end up on the posters on the subway platform. You know, the knocked out teeth, the zombie eyes, I call, you know, the blacked out or cut out eye sockets. You know, your mustache is all the way from Chaplin Hitler over to Salvador Dali style, but you know I'm a graphic designer and over time I got I got past the initial feeling of blur and then something really jumped out at me in a way the most obvious things like there's penis is drawn almost on
那是快速标签和快速涂鸦，而不是什么大作品。这些快速标签大多最终出现在地铁站台的海报上。你知道的，被打掉的牙齿、僵尸眼，我称之为，你知道的，被涂黑或挖空的眼窝。你知道的，你的胡子从卓别林、希特勒一直到萨尔瓦多·达利风格都有，但你知道我是一名平面设计师，随着时间的推移，我克服了最初的模糊感，然后有些东西真正跃入我的眼帘，就像那些显而易见的事情一样，几乎在每一个
every single poster. Gailin Smith is the author of New York Dick, a book about the Subway Penis. A primitive little symbol to be sure, but one he believes is giving voice to our true feelings about our media landscape. These posters are ubiquitous. If you haven't traveled in New York, you may not realize that they're on practically all subway
单张海报上都画着阴茎。
platforms, and there are dozens of them. They're all over the place. They're literally in your space. They're about the height you are, and they're large. Very unlike print ads, and of course, nothing like video type stuff. And you're sort of bombarded with them all the time. And even if you don't think of yourself as being bombarded,
盖林·史密斯是《纽约阴茎》一书的作者，这是一本关于地铁阴茎的书。这无疑是一个原始的小符号，但他认为它表达了我们对媒体环境的真实感受。这些海报无处不在。如果你没有去过纽约，你可能不会意识到它们实际上在所有的地铁上
you're hanging with them a lot. And it can get really tedious, especially if there's one you don't like. But in this space, in this context, you really can make your own counter-argument, your own counter-statement, and everyone knows what you mean. How is this different than, say, like a conventional authored graffiti tag? Well, I think one of the things that makes it different, and for me makes it really interesting,
平台上，而且有几十个。它们到处都是。它们字面意义上就在你的空间里。它们大约和你一样高，而且很大。与印刷广告非常不同，当然，也完全不像视频类型的东西。你某种程度上一直在被它们狂轰滥炸。即使你不认为自己受到了狂轰滥炸，
is that it's even more folkloric. There's no authorship, there's no getting famous, well known. And you're not even really getting a lot of cred with your friends. I mean, your friends may have been here giggling with you when you did it, but it's not really like you're, you know, going all city with these dingus. No one's claiming this as art.
你还是经常和它们待在一起。这可能会变得非常乏味，特别是如果有你不喜欢的。但在这个空间里，在这个语境下，你真的可以做出你自己的反驳，你自己的反声明，每个人都知道你的意思。这和传统的署名字体涂鸦有什么不同呢？嗯，我认为使它与众不同的一点，对它让我感到非常有趣的一点是，
Everyone knows it's a little stupid, but there's something about the idiocy that is part of why it works so well, and like in our culture, a way to show absolute disrespect is to draw this penis. It's like that's a very New Yorky conversation, or at least how New Yorkers like to see their themselves. Very aggressive, moderately clever,
它甚至更加具有民间色彩。没有署名，没有成名或出名。你甚至没有真正在朋友那里获得多少信誉。我是说，当你做这件事的时候，你的朋友可能一直在旁边咯咯笑，但这并不真的像你带着这些笨蛋“走遍全城”。没有人声称这是艺术。
and really sort of disrespectful. But honestly disrespectful, the person drawing a penis didn't start this conversation. They didn't think they were winning and dominating this communication. The advertiser and the system did, and so it's a way of putting some breaks on this rampant and constant getting over on one that advertising seems to feel that it's doing. I like advertising okay. I find it very interesting and away in some ads I think are really fun, but a lot of them aren't. Every time I see one of these penises now,
每个人都知道这有点蠢，但这种愚蠢正是它如此管用的原因之一，就像在我们的文化中，表现出绝对不尊重的一种方式就是画这个阴茎。这就像是一场非常纽约式的对话，或者至少是纽约人看待他们自己的方式。非常具有攻击性，适度聪明，
I get kind of excited. It's like finally proof that there are tons of people who feel the same way I do about our ever-encroaching commercial world, tons of people, and they're all saying the same thing. Screw you. Really, it's awesome. This is actually happening now with real people, making real comments in a real space, and
而且确实有点不尊重人。但老实说，这种不尊重并不是画阴茎的人挑起的。他们并不认为自己在这场交流中获胜并占据了主导地位。广告商和这个系统才是，所以这是一种对广告似乎觉得自己在做的那种猖獗且持续占便宜的行为踩刹车的方式。我挺喜欢广告的。我发现它非常有趣，而且在某些广告中我认为它们真的很有趣，但很多并不有趣。现在每次我看到这些阴茎中的一个，
it's more of a community than you might realize. And in New York City subwaysways there's potentially thousands of people that can join in that conversation or can just witness it and give that sort of a little bit of a chuckle, a little bit of a nod like, I'm not saying I agree but I know what you mean. That's an excerpt from Benjamin Walker's too much information. Find a link at the 99% Invisible website. That's 99%Invisible.org. That's it for me this week.
我就会有点兴奋。这就像终于证明了有成千上万的人对我们这个不断侵蚀的商业世界有着和我一样的感受，成千上万的人，他们都在说同一句话：滚你的吧。真的，这太棒了。这实际上正在真实的人们身上发生，在真实的太空空间中发表真实的评论，并且
I'm Roman Mars. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它比你意识到的更像一个社区。在纽约市的地铁里，潜在有成千上万的人可以加入那场对话，或者只是见证它并报以那样的一点轻笑，一点点头，就像，我不是说我同意，但我知道你的意思。那是本杰明·沃克的《太多信息》的节选。请在《99%隐形》网站上找到链接。那是 99%Invisible.org。我本周的节目就到这里。